let's go to lexington kentucky and talk
to eva
how are we doing this morning eva good
morning dr darani thank you for taking
my call
are you thank you for calling it's my
pleasure how can i help this morning
well uh i'm 61 years old and
i decided to retire next year
okay and financially we'll be fine
that's not a problem the um i'm kind of
struggling with the transition though
why are you struggling uh well you know
all our life will be working full-time
we raised three children so
our life was pretty busy and i was
always busy and i just
worry that one day i will wake up and
you know think how i'm going to justify
my existence
so you've got all the money to retire
you've raised your kids and now you're
wondering what was it all for
no no no not in this sense it's just
that
i don't want to spend the rest of my
life
you know just watching netflix and
seeing the the birds fly by
and i i have some things that i want to
do
you know but there are fun things so eva
what are they what do you want to do
well i'm thinking about riding bicycle
across
america you do it not the hard way
do it hey so what's stopping you from
going to buy an
awesome bike well besides that it's
winter um
going to get a bike and riding it across
the country what's stopping you
well no i'm going to do it yes
good but you know
it's all everything that i want to do
like travel and spend time with families
it's all fun right and i feel like
i'm you know i worry that i will feel
like i don't contribute anything
that's my problem tell me about how many
kids you have
three are they wonderful they're good
kids yes
did you do a good job
i hope so no eva did you do a good job
i guess they are not in chairs
do you have any grandkids not yet
but they're coming i hope so you know
the kids are just coming out of college
so ah okay
so here's the thing eva you deserve
to have fun and joy is
and fun and adventure is a
cornerstone part of
a good whole life and
i've never heard i've sat with a lot of
people who have passed away
i've sat with a lot of people whose
loved ones have passed away
i've never ever heard somebody say
i wish i had less fewer adventures i
wish i'd had less
fun and i wish i had just worked more
and produced more i've never heard that
sentence
that's very true yeah and one of the
things folks do when they
they get in a season of mission a season
of
focus or productivity when you got three
kids you've got a business you've been
successful so that you can grab
i mean you can uh graduate literally
graduate you can retire at 61
is you get driven and you produce and
you
focus and you do and you accomplish and
you achieve
and man if you don't stop along the way
to ride the bike across
america man that's what you're gonna
regret so i want you
ever to have as much permission as you
want
to go have fun go have adventures i know
you
you're gonna have that first grandkid
and you're gonna be that crazy grandma
who wants to move in next door you're
gonna be
all in their business and it's gonna be
so wonderful and good
maybe not for them hey it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter right but you were um
you're going to find mission
right now you want permission to just
let your hair down a little bit and you
fully fully got it
fully got it okay i guess i needed to
hear that
do you have some um some young man that
you spend time with
a young man meaning your husband
oh yeah i have my husband yes but he's a
homebody so he's
perfectly content sitting at home and
he's doing some
stuff is he still handsome oh yeah yeah
oh good
hey get a two-seater bike and strap him
to the back and you all ride across
america it's gonna be incredible you got
it
[Music]
yes i will try all right good eva
you're gonna go forever ever ever ever
and you're gonna go across america
y'all are gonna laugh and have
adventures because you've earned it
you've put in the hard work the hard
work the hard work
i'm just i'm i'm excited for you i'm
excited for it and you're going to find
purpose you're going to find
mission i already know that stuff's
going to happen you're going to be an
awesome grandparent
but you're not going to get to the end
of your days and regret not having more
joy
and you're not going to get to the end
of your days and whatever proverbial
bike ride across america is even if you
don't end up doing that even if you just
go camping or start quilting or whatever
thing it is you become a catfisher
woman what i don't know what it is
whatever you're going to do
go have adventures and have fun you're
61 you are still young
you're still beautiful you got a
handsome guy in
in in tow i'm excited for you man that's
so cool